QUESTIONS.
A LOT OF BREAKING NEWS.
WE GET STARTED IN OUR
BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
♪ ALL RIGHT.
THESE ARE MASSIVE AND HUGE
BREAKING DEVELOPMENTS
TONIGHT ABOUT WHAT IS SEVERE
OBAMA ERA FISA ABUSES.
THIS LETTER, JUST RELEASED
TONIGHT, TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS.
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
CHAIR DEVIN NUNES IS
DETAILING HOW THE FBI MAY
HAVE LITERALLY BROKEN THE
LAW AND VIOLATED BUREAU
PROTOCOLS WHEN A PAINTING
THAT FISA WARRANT TO SURVEIL
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE
CARTER PAGE.
NOW, IN THIS LETTER RELEASED
TONIGHT.
NUNES POINTS OUT SPECIFIC
DOJ GUIDELINES WHEN IT COMES
TO FISA SURVEILLANCE.
HE WRITES, QUOTE:  UNDER THE
SUBSECTION FISA VERIFICATION
AND ACCURACY PROCEDURES, THE
FBI ILLUSTRATESELF
ACKNOWLEDGES THIS
IMPORTANCE, QUOTE:  THE
ACCURACY OF INFORMATION
CONTAINED WITHIN FISA
APPLICATIONS IS OF THE
UTMOST IMPORTANCE, ONLY
DOCUMENTED AND VERIFIED
INFORMATION MAY BE USED TO
SUPPORT FBI APPLICATIONS,
FISA WARRANTS TO THE COURT.
GIVEN THIS NEW INFORMATION,
CHAIRMAN NUNES, HE IS NOW
DEMANDING THE DOJ EXPLAIN
IF, IN FACT, THESE PROTOCOLS
ARE STILL IN PLACE.
WE ALREADY KNOW THE ANSWER.
AND IF THEY'RE, THE CHAIRMAN
WANTS TO KNOW HOW OFFICIALS
WILL BE PUNISHED FOR
VIOLATING THIS LAW, LYING TO
A FISA JUDGE.
AND NOT FOLLOWING PROTOCOL.
THIS LETTER ALSO POINTS OUT
HOW USING THIS FALSE
INFORMATION IN A FISA COURT,
COULD VIOLATE SEVERAL LAWS.
LOOK AT THEM ON THE SCREEN.
18 USC 242, USING COLOR OF
LAW TO CONDUCT A TARGETED
INVESTIGATION BASED ON THE
PRETEXT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND HAVE YOU 50 USC 1809,
SURVEILLANCE CONDUCTED UNDER
COLOR OF LAW IN A MANNER NOT
CONSPIRACY OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE AND CONTEMPT OF
COURT.
WHAT THIS MEANS IS THE
SCANDAL IS GETTING BIGGER
AND BIGGER UNLIKE AN ABUSE
OF POWER WE HAVE EVER SEEN
IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY WE ARE APPEALING
LAYER AFTER LAYER OF THIS
ONION.
SARA CARTER, JASON CHAFE
VITS THE GREAT ONE MARK LA
VICTIM WILL HAVE REACTION TO
THIS TONIGHT.
ALSO BREAKING WE HAVE MORE
EVIDENCE THE TRUMP RUSSIA
COLLUSION NARRATIVE IS A
COMPLETE FARCE.
ADAM SCHIFF, THE RANKING
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE INTEL
PROFESSIONAL TRUMP HATER.
HE IS NOW ADMITTING THAT THE
SCARY, DAMNING, EARTH
SHATTERING INFORMATION THAT
HE HAS NOW BEEN PLAYING UP
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR IS
ALREADY IN THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN.
REALLY?
WHERE IS IT?
WATCH THIS.
YOU SAID YOU HAD MORE THAN
CIRCUMSTANTIAL EVIDENCE OF
TREASONOUS COLLUSION WITH
RUSSIA.
WHAT SPECIFICALLY WERE YOU
REFERRING TO AND PLEASE BE
SPECIFIC.
BECAUSE, IF IT'S TRUE, DO I
BELIEVE AMERICANS HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW A YEAR LATER
WHAT THAT IS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WELL, I CERTAINLY SAID
THAT THERE IS AMPLE EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION.
I HAVE NEVER USE YOU HAD THE
WORD TREASON.
ONLY STEVE BANNON HAS USED
THAT WORD.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE FACTS
THAT ARE ALREADY IN THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN, THEY ARE
PRETTY DAMNING.
>> IS IT ENOUGH FOR MUELLER
TO BRING CHARGES?
BECAUSE IF IT ISN'T ENOUGH
FOR MUELLER TO BRING
CHARGES, WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN?
>> WELL,.
>> CHARGES OF COLLUSION.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION.
THAT IS WHAT IS MUELLER'S
JOB AND WHAT IS OUR JOB?
BOB MUELLER WILL MAKE THE
DECISION WHETHER THERE IS
PROOF BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT TO INDICT AND CONVICT
PEOPLE.
IT IS NOT HIS RESPONSIBILITY
TO TELL THE COUNTRY WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> Sean: AMAZING JOB MEGHAN
MCCAIN.
LET ME GIVE YOU HAVE THE
TRANSLATION.
ADAM SCHIFF IS ACCUSING
TRUMP OF COLLUSION WITH
LITTLE MORE SPECULATION,
RUMOR AND PHONY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER NEVER CORROBORATED
OR VERIFIED.
DO YOU SEE HOW SEVERE THIS
IS?
NOW WE MAY WELL FIND OUT IN
COMING WEEKS OR MONTHS THAT
SCHIFF'S CONSTANT ANTI-TRUMP
FIVE ALARM FIRES HAS BEEN
NOTHING MORE THAN POLITICAL
HYPERBOLE MEANT TO DAMAGE A
SITTING PRESIDENT THAT YOU
VOTED FOR, SO HE COULD WIN
FAVOR WITH HIS LIBERAL BASE
AND GET HIRED BY CONSPIRACY
AND IS PROBABLY WHY,
ACCORDING TO THE RNC, SCHIFF
HAS APPEARED ON TELEVISION
227 TIMES SINCE PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S INAUGURATION.
IT'S ONLY A MATTER OF TIME
WHERE MSNBC HIRES HIM.
MAYBE HE WILL TAKE OVER FOR
MATT LAUER WHO HAS BEEN OUT
FOR A WHILE.
ALSO BRAND NEW TONIGHT
ROBERT MUELLER FACING
CRITICISM FOR SOMEONE WHO
HAS INTIMATE KNOWLEDGE OF
SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATIONS.
KENNETH STARR YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER, INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL, RESPONSIBLE FOR
INVESTIGATING BILL CLINTON
IN THE 1990S.
HE IS SAYING THAT MUELLER,
SAYING, MIGHT BE CROSS AGO
LINE.
WATCH THIS.
>> BOB MUELLER, LOOKING INTO
TRUMP'S BUSINESS DEALINGS
BEFORE 2016 TO SEE IF THERE
WAS POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITY
FOR EXERTION OF INFLUENCE BY
RUSSIAN ANY KIND OF ACTORS
ON THEIR PART, FAIR POINT?
>> I THINK IT'S BEYOND HIS
MANDATE.
THE MANDATE IS WHAT HAPPENED
DURING THE 2016 ELECTION IN
TERMS OF COLLUSION.
IN FACT, I THINK THAT THE
INDICTMENT ALMOST TWO WEEKS
AGO OF THE 13 RUSSIAN
NATIONALS AND THE THREE
COMPANIES SUGGEST THERE WAS
NO COLLUSION.
MY SENSE WOULD BE BUT I
DON'T HAVE ALL THE FACTS,
BOB, I LOVE YOU, BUT LET'S
JUST STAY FOCUSED ON WHAT
THE ISSUE IS AND THAT'S
COLLUSION IN THE CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: STARR WENT ON TO
EXPLAIN WHILE MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION MUST REMAIN
NARROWLY FOCUSED IT'S UP TO
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
IS HE RIGHT, ROD ROSENSTEIN
OVERSEEING THIS CASE TO KEEP
MUELLER ON TASK.
REMEMBER, THIS WHOLE
WITCH-HUNT WAS ONLY SUPPOSED
TO BEEN TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THAT EVIDENCE DOES NOT EXIST
ALL OF THIS TIME SPEAKING OF
RUSSIA.
THINK ABOUT THIS, WITH ALL
OF THAT TALK WE HAVE ANOTHER
MAJOR BREAKING NEWS STORY
TONIGHT, THAT'S THE RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT, THE BAD ACTOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THAT'S RIGHT.
THE GUY THAT OBAMA SAID
WASN'T A BAD ACTOR AND TELL
WLADIMIR I WILL HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY AFTER THE
ELECTIONS.
REMEMBER THAT GUY.
BRAND NEW NUCLEAR WEAPONS
THAT CAN PENETRATE AMERICA'S
DEFENSES.
PUTIN MADE THE ANNOUNCEMENT
DURING A STATES OF NATION
SPEECH.
HE DETAILED HOW THESE NEW
WEAPONS LITERALLY INCLUDE A
NUCLEAR POWER CRUISE MISSILE
AND KNEW HYPER SONIC MISSILE
AND NUCLEAR POWERED
UNDERWATER DRONE.
U.S. OFFICIALS ARE CASTING A
LOT OF DOUBT ON PUTIN'S
COMMENTS BUT SAYING THAT HIS
NEW CRUISE MISSILE IS STILL
IN THE TEST PHASE AND HAS
CRASHED A FEW TIMES.
OKAY.
HERE IS MY POINT TONIGHT.
HAVE YOU THE LIBERAL MEDIA
AND THE DEMOCRATS OBSESSING,
TOTAL-OBSESSED OVER A
CONSPIRACY THEORY TRUMP
RUSSIA COLLUSION EVEN THOUGH
WE HAVE ZERO EVIDENCE PUTIN
EVERY SINGLE DAY AS WE ARE
DOING THIS IS GETTING
STRONGER.
AND THE LEFT AND THE MEDIA
ARE LITERALLY PLAYING RIGHT
INTO PUTIN AND RUSSIA'S
HANDS.
NOW, PUTIN'S ENTIRE GOAL,
WHAT IS IT?
TO SOW POLITICAL DISCORD IN
AMERICA.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE
LEFT.
MEDIA ARE LITERALLY DOING BY
GOING DOWN THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION RABBIT HOLE WITH
NO EVIDENCE.
THEN THERE IS BARACK OBAMA
AND HILLARY CLINTON.
REMEMBER OBAMA?
MOCKING MITT ROMNEY FOR
DARING TO CALL RUSSIA A
THREAT AND THEN IGNORE
THREATS, SPECIFIC THREAT
2014 FROM DEVIN NUNES AND
OTHERS ON THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE AND HE TOLD
PRESIDENT TRUMP STOP WHINING
ABOUT THE ELECTION AND
ELECTION INTERFERENCE JUST
DAYS BEFORE THE ELECTION.
HILLARY CLINTON STUPIDLY,
REMEMBER THAT STILLLY RESET
BUTTON, GOING TO RESET
RELATIONS WITH RUSSIA.
SHE HELPED TO PROVE GIVING
RUSSIA AND PUTIN CONTROL OF
IT 20% OF OUR URANIUM.
THEN SHE PAID FOR THE
RUSSIAN DOSSIER FILLED WITH
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT LIES.
YOU HE NO, SO GREAT JOB UMED
AND DEMOCRATS.
YOU HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB
DIVIDING THE COUNTRY AND
LYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WITHOUT EVIDENCE AND PUSHING
BASELESS CONSPIRACY THEORIES
BECAUSE YOU HATE DONALD
TRUMP AND VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
GETTING STRONGER.
NOW, WE HAVE MORE BREAKING
NEWS TONIGHT.
THIS STORY IS OUTRAGEOUS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
TRYING TO DETERMINE IF THE
MAYOR OF OAK LAND, IF SHE
LITERALLY OBSTRUCTED
JUSTICE, WARNING CRIMINAL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ABOUT ICE
RAIDS.
THIS LIBERAL MAYOR, WELL,
SHE TOOK TO TWITTER ON
SATURDAY AND TO ALTER
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND WARN
THEM IN THE OAKLAND AREA
THAT, HEY, FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES ARE
PREPARING TO CONDUCT
OPERATIONS.
NOW, THE ACTING HEAD OF ICE
IS BLASTING MAYOR SAYING
THAT HER STUNT ALLOWED ABOUT
800 CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS TO AVOID ARREST.
HE ALSO SAID THIS ON "FOX &
FRIENDS" THIS MORNING, TAKE
A LOOK.
>> WHAT SHEARER DID WAS NO
BETTER THAN A GANG LOOKOUT
CALLING OUT POLICE WHEN A
POLICE COMES INTO THE
COMMUNITY.
BEYOND THE PALE.
I HAVE BEEN DOING THIS 4 U.
34 YEARS.
BOY ITEMLY WARN LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BEING THAT A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IS DIFFICULT ENOUGH.
INFORMING COMING IN THE NEXT
24 INCREASES.
AMERICAN HEROES STRAP A GUN
TO THEIR HIP EVERY DAY.
TELL CRIMINALS WE ARE COMING
IN THE NEXT 24 HOURS IS
INCREDIBLE.
>> Sean: MAYOR OF OAKLAND
AIDING AND ABETTING CRIMINAL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND OF
COURSE DEFENDING HER ACTIONS
WRITING ON TWITTER NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES.
I DON'T REGRET SHARING THIS
INFORMATION.
IT IS OAKLAND'S LEGAL RIGHT
TO BE A SANCTUARY CITY AND
WE HAVE NOT BROKEN ANY LAWS.
WE BELIEVE OUR COMMUNITY IS
SAFER WHEN FAMILIES STAY
TOGETHER.
OKAY.
THEY DID BREAK LAWS.
WE HAVE LAWS ON THE BOOKS.
IT'S PATHETIC.
BUT WHAT THE MAYOR IS NOT
SAYING AND CLEARLY OBVIOUSLY
DOESN'T REALIZE OR CARE IS
THAT NOT ONLY IS SHE PUTTING
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES'
LIVES AT RISK, SHE IS DOING
THE SAME THING FOR AMERICAN
CITIZENS IN HER COMMUNITY.
NOW, ICE IS SAYING ALL THEY
ARE TRYING TO DO GET THE BAD
PEOPLE OFF THE STREET GUESS
WHAT IF ANY OF THE CRIMINAL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COMMIT A
CRIME THE BLOOD WILL BE ON
HER HANDS AND LITERALLY SHE
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
WHATEVER HAPPENS.
SHE OWNS THIS.
NOW WE HAVE A MAJOR UPDATE
TOO TONIGHT ON THE FLORIDA
SCHOOL SHOOTING.
FOX NEWS REPORTING THE
COMMANDING OFFICER WE ARE
THE SCENE DURING NIKOLAS
CRUZ'S RAMPAGE LITERALLY
ORDERED SOME OF THE FIRST
RESPONDERS DEPUTIES TO SET
UP A PERIMETER INSTEAD OF
CONFRONTING AND NEUTRALIZING
THIS MAD MAN.
THIS GUNMAN.
THIS NEW PIECE OF
INFORMATION IS BEYOND
STUNNING.
NOW THE BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE POLICY FOR
DEALING WITH ACTIVE SHOOTER
SITUATION SAYS FIRST
RESPONDERS MAY GO INTO A
BUILDING TO SAVE LIVES
WITHOUT PERMISSION.
>> THE POLICY DOES NOT
APPEAR TO ABOUT SETTING UP
THE PERIMETER.
IF THAT'S THE CAVES THE
QUESTION IS WHY DID FOUR
BROWARD COUNTIES SHERIFF'S
DEPUTIES NOT RUSH INTO THE
SCHOOLING CORAL CAPABLES TO
SAVE LIVES DELAYS IN
ALLOWING ENTTS TO GO INSIDE
THE SCHOOL.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT KIDS
LITERALLY.
PRECHES SEEING AMOUNTS AND
THE BROWERED CAN SHERIFF'S
OFFICE.
THIS IS ONE HUGE MASSIVE BIG
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRATIC
CRATIC FAILURE AT EVERY
LEVEL.
THE GOVERNMENT FAILED THE
PEOPLE OF FLORIDA.
AND AS WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
YOU, BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF
SCOTT ISRAEL IS REFUSING TO
ACCEPT EVEN AN OUNCE OF
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND HE IS ALSO SAYING THAT
HE LIKELY WILL NOT RELEASE
VIDEO OF HOW DEPUTIES
RESPONDED SO THAT WE, YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN SEE